there have been great horror movies from
every decade but if you get brutal and
start hacking away eventually each
decade will have just one classic horror
film left standing directed by Jennifer
Kent the babadook deals with one of the
most serious and studied topics in all
of horror grief whether the titles top
hat wearing demon is real metaphorical
or a weird combo of both he's one of the
most powerful symbols of death and
anguish in cinema history
then there's SC Davis whose performance
as a mother on the verge of collapse is
both heartbreaking and horrific and even
looking past the symbolism the babadook
is just straight-up terrifying
everything here drips with dread from
that creepy pop-up book - Noah Wiseman's
devilish performance as a troubled
little kid in a decade build with
remarkable films the babadook is the one
that will talk horror fans for years to
come see him in your room at night set
in a desolate Stockholm Let The Right
One In follows a twelve-year-old boy
named Oskar who befriends a seemingly
young girl named Ellie both look
innocent but they harbored disturbing
secrets Oskar is regularly bullied at
school and spends his nights plotting
gruesome revenge and Elly is a
centuries-old vampire who drinks the
life force of human beings bleak and
snowy on the surface the movies heart is
bloody and red it isn't easy being a
monster and let the right one in takes a
look at these twisted creatures and all
their messy murderous complexity the
Silence of the Lambs is the only horror
movie so far to win the Best Picture
Oscar and only a fool would argue that
it wasn't deserved while the movie is
anchored by Jodie Foster's toughest nail
performances Clarice Starling its legend
has lasted so long
thanks to Anthony Hopkins as Hannibal
Lecter Hopkins created one of the
greatest movie monsters of all time calm
creepy and charismatic he can discuss
literature one minute devour your liver
the next a census taken Alana's time to
test
I ate his liver with some fava beans and
a nice Chianti directed by the legendary
Stanley Kubrick The Shining is a big
cult Lamberth of a movie Kubrick's use
of the Steadicam following little Danny
Torrance around the Overlook is
groundbreaking and both Jack Nicholson
and Shelley Duvall give heighten
performances that perfectly match the
overwhelming presence of the hotel while
it's a technical masterpiece it's also
one of the scariest films ever made
The Shining is a nightmare that never
stops and just like a bad dream will be
trying to decipher its meaning for years
to come darling my light let me finish
William Friedkin's The Exorcist is a
film so iconic that it's become the
standard for every scary movie ever
since nearly 50 years later we've seen
this possession story a million times so
it might be hard for modern audiences to
appreciate the Exorcist as the world
shattering nausea-inducing game-changer
that it was at the time the special
effects were out of this world and
audiences were repelled by the puking
and the head twisting but under all that
slimy green goo this movie worked so
well because it's got such beautifully
well written characters the acting is
oscar-worthy and the final confrontation
between good and evil still resonates
directed by Alfred Hitchcock psycho was
a game-changing film that's buried its
way deep into the pop-culture
consciousness Bernard Herrmann's
violence score is just as iconic as
Anthony Perkins performance as the
quietly creepy Norman Bates he's both
the sympathetic and psychotic and that
infamous shower scene is still one of
the scariest horror moments of all time
sure it's been parodied to death but in
1960 it was an absolute shock with that
brutal knife attack psycho became the
granddaddy of the slasher genre well
it's not as bloody as modern horror
psycho is still an unsettling film that
will make you think twice about checking
into a hotel an invasion of the body
snatchers dr. Myles Bernal is a
clean-cut doctor living in a wholesome
American neighborhood however the good
doctor soon realizes that all his
friends are being replaced by alien
doppelgangers these replacements are
cold calculating and planning to take
over the world using plant pods that
grow clones to replace human beings sure
the idea of pod people might sound a
little corny and some of the effects are
a bit hokey but the movie is still
effective because it's completely soaked
in suspicion and dread the idea of being
replaced consumed and changed by some
malevolent force is truly chilling
cat-people follows a young woman named
Irene who's got a bit of trouble in the
intimacy Department she's worried about
getting intimate with her new husband
because she thinks if she gets aroused
she'll turn into a black panther and rip
his head off it's a pretty strong case
for abstinence although we're not sure
if Irene is just troubled or if there's
actually some evil magic running through
her family tree and that's why cat
people is such a masterpiece it plays on
the fear of the unknown by keeping the
killer cat woman off screen in the
film's most famous sequence a woman is
walking down a deserted street late at
night becoming more and more sure that
she's being pursued by something inhuman
it's a powerfully paced sequence and
proof enough that cat people holds up
released in 1931 Dracula wasn't the
first vampire movie or even the first
movie inspired by Bram Stoker's novel
but it did establish the undead ideal
all thanks to actor Bela Lugosi
with his hypnotic hands and Hungarian
accent Lugosi set the mold for every
vampire film to come and every line he
delivers is both creepy and charming
aristocratic and eerie thanks to this
seductive bloodsucker horror became one
of Hollywood's most popular genres
[Music]
it's delicious check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorites
topper coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]